[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with an astonishing
admission about one of britain's most
popular sports
last night in an unprecedented statement
all of england's major cricketing bodies
apologize for racism in the sport
it follows testimony given to british
lawmakers by one former professional
player this week mts tab reports from
london and how azim rafiq's evidence has
impacted britain the details can be
difficult to hear
it's known as the gentleman's game
cricket has grown over the centuries to
become a global industry beloved by
billions around the world but this week
searing allegations of institutional
racism have shattered the normally
gentile facade of the birthplace of
cricket
england pretty early on
me and other people
from asian background there was comments
such as you lot sit over there near the
toilets the allegations were brought
forward by britain's azim rafiq no one
could ever whose tearful testimony this
week in front of lawmakers about his
experiences as a top-level player for
yorkshire county cricket club left the
nation stunned
felt isolated
humiliated at times
constant use of the word [ __ ]
in britain the word [ __ ] is a racist
slur directed at people of south asian
descent that is often compared with the
n-word for the potency of its hate
according to rafiq the racism he
experienced included being held down by
teammates at just 15 years old and as a
practicing muslim as a professional
adult player poured wine down his throat
claiming the highest levels of cricket
would cover up the hateful abuse he
received it's been gaslighting it's been
yet but
yeah but but there is no yet brought to
racism there is no two sides to a story
when it comes to racism rafiq's
testimony has triggered a racial
reckoning in britain
including this moment on the nation's
biggest morning show and if you're
british asian pakistani like azim is or
indian like i am or bangladeshi or sri
lanka and it hit differently because it
takes you
to that place in your mind where you
experience some of what he
talked about all of them here bose is a
british indian journalist who's covered
cricket for nearly half a century the
england team
both at the international level at the
county level has become very wide and
the qriket authorities somehow haven't
seen this as a problem they've said zero
tolerance on racism but what does that
mean in practice a day after rafiq's
searing testimony text messages written
by him over 11 years ago were published
containing an anti-semitic trope leading
british jewish groups have defended
rafiq who since apologized saying quote
he suffered terribly at the hands of
racists in cricket and we have no reason
to believe he is not completely sincere
rifik's testimony has prompted other
players to share their experiences of
racism leaving the gentleman's game in
the gutter of public opinion
until meaningful reforms are made
for cbs saturday morning india's taj
london
it seems like if you don't raise the
curtain on this if you just say it's a
zero tolerance and it goes on it doesn't
change you need a moment like this to
say it is going on and it's not
acceptable and continue the conversation
always because it's not going to go away
overnight it just won't
well